hmm it's probably pretty broken and the
bad news is
also what's with all these annoying
songs
the bad news is i can't react to you
yelling at me
yan the layout is broken because i can't
see it
so spearman 666
like his great predecessor rudolph
spielman
decides to gambit a pawn so daring
and i'll do him a favor and accept that
very pawn
this sounds annoying can we switch over
the zones why did nobody ever tell me
how this site works
so bishop f5 looks like a decent enough
move my plan is to go e6
and then not to blunder any tactics
connected to
knight to e5 and bishop back knight
takes f7 or rook takes f5 so after 95
you go bishop g6
and yes i did spend most of my childhood
studying the what's it called
um i don't know what's called the
black martinemer gambit is that it and
reinforcements are coming
the naked world champion has emerged
from the shower
i can see him but i'm not sure
wow but just socks i'm not sure
i will have a lawsuit on my hands if i
turn the camera
in the naked socks direction so he's in
the building ladies and gentlemen
spielman is out of the book which might
be even worse than
being in the building also how broken is
the layout
someone tell me
[Music]
bored with low names and times a little
low otherwise okay that's good enough
for our standards
and the champ is here i
would have to do this again i wanna this
is the first game i want to first of all
i'm very happy with myself
it looks like a very good carry-on i
have to say
but isn't he going to take an e6 with
the name of spielmann
there is no choice right you got a you
gotta sack something
he's been studying his position for like
two minutes yeah i was expecting to
blitz out bishop v6 and i'd hope i was
hoping you'd be back in time to take it
exactly
so but i think spielman has a whole
chapter in his book about
exactly this the sack like sac something
on e6 before
black and castle anybody who's a better
historian than i am
could chime in here but uh did you read
rudolph spielman books
that's amazing what can i say
i was uh i was a hard worker in my youth
so okay so after all of this he came up
with uh
rookie one which makes uh
close to perfect sense fairly decent
what can i say sorry i got you this mess
you're gonna have to get us something
yeah wow we should be six you're just
gonna castle
no i i i don't know so what i'm thinking
was that
yeah this is not too dangerous i suppose
uh what i was thinking
uh bishop e6 maybe i could take queen d7
go king d8 run that way
but the point was if rook e6 i don't
really think i can take
but maybe we could play h6 then but now
i don't think
it's uh particularly dangerous
we are just uh too many um
strong strong points like
there just isn't enough
do you think spielman will feel cheated
that
he thought he was just checkmating
stupid young and then you managed to
come out of the shower in time or will
he be happy that he gets to play you
i think uh spielman would ha will have
decidedly mixed feelings
so queen e2 that is a clever try
because long castles is no longer
available so i'm guessing
this one is gonna be
the move or not so my line was knight d5
knight d5
not cd5-ish b4 uh bishop d5
cd bishop g5 bishop e4 but now i'm
realizing
takes once he could go bishop g5
so maybe i made a little mistake
yeah i'm just trying to look smart like
hi
what do you think you're gonna you're
gonna help me go knight cd5
and he's gonna take twice and then go
um we got to show you forward but we
gotta
hold uh ourselves to a higher step yeah
whatever but we'll do
that
do you know if people in general listen
into the show while they're
while they're playing so that they can
get a couple of tips
i think there's some delay like a couple
seconds so they might do it early but it
becomes a competitive disadvantage once
time gets slow
but yeah we have to be careful yeah not
sharing
all these great ideas like king d8
exactly
it seemed like he's surprised that he
was surprised anyway
as far as i can remember would have spin
one was a very
decent honest chap so his
successor is that's what it was
very fair play
while he's thinking i'm gonna have
myself a piece of
a very old banana
i didn't dare touch it i searched the
whole flat while you were gone on your
secret mission but all i saw was this
very old looking banana and i thought he
probably wants that later
yeah they're supposed to be even
healthier you know
old ones yeah okay i don't know why but
i've heard it
and they're really good for making like
banana waffles and
banana bread and all of these things
that i don't know how to make
naive people just zooming in to learn
something about chess now i have a new
banana recipe for the rest of their life
we're not winning right
yeah completely winning um
there's um for economics podcasts about
banana the most interesting fruit in the
world
so um i could i listened to that and now
i consider myself a
banana expert okay but don't you think
bananas
consistency that word is slightly wrong
like i think it should belongs in the
mixer
it's obviously a good fruit right i
think it should be part of stuff
i i agree but it has so much going for
it
but it's um it's threatened like at
least um
the main brand the cavendish banana is
um it's got the
panama disease so it's uh slowly dying
so we got um like all of
basically all the bananas we eat in the
west are of the same
same type if you go uh other places like
when i was in the cote d'ivoire then
there are uh local banana
types but the ones you find uh the ones
that are cheap you find in supermarkets
everywhere it's it's all the same type
and that one is dying so we need a new
banana type
i don't know it yeah
as i said the most interesting fruit in
the world
now there is not much time not much
position left for
[Music]
you know people are really gonna get on
our case right because
when when i play i only talk about chess
no they're they're already hating me
like they're thinking okay this was such
an interesting game and
yeah yeah magnus only talk about bananas
they give us explanations
i apologize my fault i will get out of
the
picture for the next game